[Music]
what's up thank you stickers stick of
tears stick gums it is monday morning
january 31st what's poppin how's
everybody doing out there man how's the
kids
how'd your weekend go
huh how's it going man everybody good
out there because i can hear you that's
what i'm talking to you um what's going
on man good to see you guys your boy is
fresh off
uh the tough mudder the thick mudder in
lake elsinore and i want to thank
everybody who came out
and uh
your boys sore today your boy so did
casey ran it casey finished first out of
the whole thick boy
crew he finished first casey crushed it
um
casey crushed it and then uh meatball
christian hung with jay and chappelle in
the back
so the way it goes so we had over 400
thick
thick boys and gals sign up to run with
me
the way it works though is there and i
didn't know this right i don't
specialize in uh tough mudders i just
run them you know but uh the way it
works is there's different tiers so
i think online it
said 10 a.m which the if you sign up for
the think boy it was 10 a.m
and i thought it'd be all 400 of us run
at the same time
but they can't do that because there's
all the obstacles and then it would take
forever to finish so they broke us up in
like four different groups yeah when you
think about it i can't dad no [ __ ]
dumbass so for the people that didn't
get to run with me i apologize but i did
see afterwards i saw you before and
after so that still works and for the
people that ran with me i mean you're
just talking about some freaking
loyal ass hardcore dudes man and gals
there's some gals a
gnarly man they were they're beating
most the guys um
it's just a good time man it's just a
great time
this one i think they heard me after i
finished uh my first uh tough mudder a
few months ago i was like man wasn't
that muddy and whoever puts these
together is like
oh you want mud say less so this one it
was all mud it was
all mud and water and lake elsinore
gorgeous out there never been lake el
snort is uh
you know it's just not very um
uh warm
during the time it's not warm so you're
going cold hot cold hot cold cold cold
cold hot uh big freaking uh mark harley
was shaking his lips were shaking up and
down um he i thought he was going to
pass away but he didn't
and it's so interesting because when you
dude yeah you're showing this it's
so we ran as a team
there's nothing i hate more
it's shut look i just
i got out of there i get out of it
and then you'll see like instantly
hammies were not good
this was what ruined
this is what ruined me
there's mud in my there's my
brother-in-law that's steven there he
ran with us
they get the ham bones
[Applause]
that's really the whole crew that so
deposit or you can if you i'm covering
them now this dude ran into all saints
uh leopard print uh shirt just mr
fashion man yeah alex yeah it was great
he was cool
it's it's just it's just such a dope
thing man like it's just it's just
it's just
my hammies were so shot there dude when
i say i couldn't
go another mile like when we got there i
looked at everyone was like if this was
one more mile i wouldn't finish this i
don't know it was a mental but my body
like my both calves were cramping my
quad was cramping the the the hammies
were just literally they're like dude
this is it man we've gotten to this
point anymore and we're done and what's
interesting is my left hand me when i
race chabelle the left hand was the one
that was the big issue the the most
gnarly injury right
um so i put all my time into making sure
the left was good i did nothing for the
right because it really didn't hurt that
much on the day of the race the right
was the one giving me problems because
left i had a wrap over it i had all this
stuff but the right one was giving me
the problem it was probably also over
compensating the correct side because
the left was weak correct yeah so um
just thank god i made through and thank
god i did it too man because
i'd say it's just dope we're gonna do a
lot more of these um
you know probably four to six more this
year
all you know all over not just in
california the next one might be in
california but um we're gonna do them
all over and i'm telling you if you ever
thought about challenging yourself and
like going through an experience
and you know there's people like man we
didn't know if we could do this and we
thought it was gonna be this or this
i'm telling you it's more of like a team
thing it's not even about your cardio or
any of that stuff it's just about
bonding and getting through this
challenge it's just fun man it's just
fun i've never even run that far yeah
and i was able to do it i thought it was
gonna be way harder
i thought it was going to be way harder
and i didn't know how fun it was going
to be it was way more fun than i thought
and i was totally able to do it having
never run out and you make friends you
know so you're basically doing like a
three to four hour podcast with this
crew it's so interesting because you
start off right you're like all you
start off the starting line all together
and as you get going as it gets more
difficult and you know along the journey
you slowly your crew comes from about 40
people to 30 to 20 to 15. then by then
there's just 10 of you hardcores
together trying to get through it men
but it's just so much fun dude i met
some great people a lot of other dads
out there you know we talked about dad
life out there on the trails and
it was just a really really cool
experience man
a lot of mud a lot of mud uh
literally as as we're i'm take i'm
saying
i'm gonna say two minutes into it my
brother's running with me i'm like just
don't stop just stay up with me just
don't stop
two minutes of me is where's chappelle
at man i'm he starts walking like what
he's like where's chappelle chappelle so
he goes back with chappelle so
we finished in about my crew finished
probably what'd you finish in casey
under three hours and i was like 3 30 i
think 345 probably and i think chappelle
and jay finish about
four and a half almost five
probably five a little after five
you know a little after five i was like
three beers deep by the time they got
done yeah
yeah so
uh but there's a video of chappelle
we'll get in and find the kid but
you know you don't realize how athletic
chappelle is uh there's a wall it's
about 20 foot wall and on the left
people can run up single it's tough i
like with my legs i can't do it but on
the left you can
just run up without the rope and you
gotta like grab on this thing and pull
yourself up on the right there's rope
where 90
98 of people run up and grab the rope
chappelle's ass decide to do the left
and that you know this is like
mile seven so you're pretty fatigued
this dude chappelle [ __ ] sean kemp
this thing my brother's like i'm telling
me
yeah i see this he runs and then two
hand like this like
whack and gratton pulls himself up it's
a great video it's on fire the kid is a
great video like god damn chappelle is
athletic you got up on the left too
yeah there's there's certain parts where
i would look and i'd go can't well i
can't explode i can't jump i can't you
know sprint like that so there's just
certain parts i can't do
this over here this is what
[Applause]
happy chappelle's why is shirts off i
don't know
it's not warm look at you watch him how
happy he is
to walk in the park just to walk in the
park
isn't that great awesome yeah
it's just a great time man it's a great
time
uh callan didn't show up
he texts him about 8 p.m on friday night
the night before hey man i was playing
10 i messed up my calf i'm not gonna
make it okay
makes sense
he gave me his whole pitch on how uh he
can't be around mud because of his baby
and we'll get into him find the kid okay
yep so but shout out to everybody who
came um it was just a great great time
man i made a lot of real really good
friends
and uh again when we do more we do a lot
more of them man we'll do a lot more of
them
the best thing is they're all different
like this one was completely different
than what i did the first time
the electric thing hey tough mudder love
you guys you know this you know you know
i mess with you guys i love the tough
mudders i always want to do them now i'm
in business with you guys
can we stop with electrocution can you
well i mean come on it's the last thing
can we stop with that i i hate it i when
i i can't emphasize enough i hate it
dude
everything up the mud dude put mud up my
butt do whatever you want the ice plunge
all for it dunk them under water the
tear gas all for it
the electrocution i hate it i hate it
man is it just a mental thing how did
you no it hurt no no no it's not no it
[ __ ]
hurts dude all right let's see casey
it's well first of all you ran through
it like the tough way like getting hit
by all of them i'm little i crouched
under and i only got shocked once oh no
i was trying i got it like 20 times and
it's it's not like it's not good it's
like
like i was like um
and that's why i dove i was like
and what's interesting is like
everyone's like
to me it's awful i hate i can't
emphasize enough i don't hate many
things in this life i hate that thing
man um but that's like the big moment
definition thing and you run as a team
but like my brother he got shocked and
he got shocked right on his like trap he
has this huge bruise there now he's like
it really didn't bother me a lot of
people like yeah i didn't really feel it
and then other people like i so it
depends i don't know why but certain
people like
the people i like i uh was eating
afterwards like with the the thick crew
the the people who ran with me were all
eating you know and i was like the
electric they're like that was awful but
then like one guy's like i didn't feel
anything like how it's weird how it
affects different people i wonder if
there's different strengths because like
some were white some were like yellow i
wonder if like the white ones were
really strong because i got shocked by
the white one and it like i i it shot me
like a candy it yeah it literally made
forced me to fall down and it felt like
my hands went
and now they're all bruised so you guys
have been um shocked before right with
like the taser gun not the actual gun
gun but the the little thing yeah
worse than that right where's the more
powerful than that when i had that
happen to me i'm like it's not a big
deal so i wonder if that's me but that's
what cops say too like uh you know my
father-in-law cop for 30 years he was
saying certain people the taser yeah he
was like you'll hit him and it does
nothing and he said especially if
they're on meth or something like he's
like you're like oh why why don't you
just use the taser of the gun like well
because we know the gun works on
everybody the taser sometimes it doesn't
work on certain people i i wonder what
it is but hey
if you need to stop me stop it if you
need to tase my ass dude i wish we had
video of jay shop
again we were so far i didn't see him
completing stuff but he did it god bless
them
there's a part where you got to go it's
like pink water and you got to go upside
down and climb and go through and you
have about
literally if your face there you it
covers everything but your mouth eyes
and nose your ears are so you're like
this going underwater right
i don't know j i'm claustrophobic too
and jay shop's claustrophobic and he got
in that thing and apparently i mean he
said like
because he's a you know he's a heavy guy
so he thought he could grab like the the
fence and like crawl up it and he said
he got it and he was fine mate halfway
and then he was like what how do i just
sink in so he grabbed pull himself up
because he's [ __ ] large he's also a
thick boy he pulled and the thing gave
so they went
and they said it was like cat it was
like a marlin being caught he started
like
spinning around everyone's like jesus
christ dude said he almost died i mean
like what that's freaky yeah yeah
really yeah isn't that weird that's the
easiest part for me
because i did the same thing where i'm
like i'm watching people so i'm trying
to observe how to do it right never done
it before so i'm like all right if you
climb it like a fence you'll be good but
i did the same thing where i pulled down
the fence and that actually gives you
less space so then i was like all right
calm down
you're fine like take take it easy and i
put my arms behind me and pushed my face
towards the fence so then i had more
room yeah first thing you pull it down
and you're like it's it's just dicey
it's dicey freezing
that was that that was the only thing
that bothered me about the back of my
neck was freezing cold in that water
like freezing cold then for my ham he's
going
cold call cold run run run cold call
cold run run run coco run and by then so
many people are cramping up and just
so i yeah you know i'm always gonna do
the 15k but i think what we're gonna
offer next is the 15k and the 5k like
jay and chappelle should have done the
5k
if you're not like if you don't do any
cardio do the five can you be fine
and then i'd also i know they want to
break it up into you know the four
tiers the four heats
but maybe we can just do two so i i love
when everyone's around me i love because
we're all doing it together helping each
other but it was it was so much fun man
it was so much fun and you know what
your boy so my goal doing carnivore diet
a to get lighter to run this thing
and uh
you know be with the injury and stuff i
thought it'd help being lighter
and so i was like right as soon as i
finish the tough mudder i'm gonna go
nuts on carbs and just eat all this
stuff
and i was like i'm good man i still
didn't break the diet very nice i ate uh
the hot dogs that always literally gets
me through the race thinking the hot dog
didn't eat the bun just just ate the dog
and then i got two uh burger patties
from a food truck and that's that night
i stuck to the diet too so i went
straight from there uh lake elsinore
which is about an hour outside san diego
and me and big j drove straight from
there
down to san diego where crystal leah was
headlining the laugh factory laugh at
laugh factory san diego um new club i
think it opened in june of last year
but they're just with the with the you
know the kova district stuff like that
they just started uh getting uh booking
headliners
so i've never been down there oh what's
he doing there
that's hilarious
oh i seen a cape
i didn't see that hi carlson um
[Music]
but yeah i've never been down there it's
in like the heart of fricken
it's in the heart of uh san diego san
diego yeah it's like right there
and uh just a great club man the crowd
was rocking it reminds me of blend of la
jolla comedy store
and the comedy works in denver if they
had a baby it's so dope see it's about
300.
so i went down there surprised chris's
fans i was the special guest and they're
just great shows man awesome stay at my
favorite hotel down there the pendry
it's my absolute favorite hotel what's
weird is this you know san diego's a
college military town
bro we when we got out of the you know
out of the late show so it's around
midnight
dude it is the purge around that
[ __ ] it is
i mean not so's dude
i mean not so's just because we it's
only three blocks in the hotel so we're
walking we saw several fights we saw i
saw one guy get [ __ ] tased another
guy got maced i was like what is
happening just drunk young people man a
lot of energy
love san diego absolutely love san diego
i mean j shop drove back that morning we
had to listen to the games on the radio
which i actually prefer am radio i love
listening games on the radio um
you know nfl's popping man rams are in
the god they're doing it their goddamn
my boy cooper cup what's up dude i
[ __ ] up because i'm dude
waiting to do this spell i'll announce
it for the super bowl to do something
cool for the super bowl and i was like i
need a coupe cooper cup jersey if he
wins this game i'm finding him about
he's my favorite player i'm like i'm
going to buy his [ __ ] jersey as soon
as they want i go online nfl shop go to
buy the jersey
the all black ram streets filthy with a
super well logo on it and i was like
i'll wear that during the thing i'm
going to do for the super bowl
this is shipping estimate
there it is right there [ __ ] february
28th i can't
i can't get jiggy to this
what do you want me to do with that man
i gotta i need it for the super bowl
they're sold out look at that i
literally did it bright when he won i
see if he wins this game i i gotta
represent for my boy man eastern
washington
this small white kid from eastern
washington and he's the best player in
the nfl best receiver hauler man how can
he not [ __ ] with that guy
so uh yeah now i was going for my
cincinnati and rams is exactly what i
wanted so here we are man here we are
but uh again shout out to all the the
thick mudders out there
um those thick mudder shirts we were
wearing we'll put available online
um so you'll be able to get them there
i'll give you guys a discount too so if
you ran the thick mutter and you want
that shirt that my whole team was
rocking we'll have those online soon
i'll post all about all that but uh
yeah man great weekend your boys sore no
doubt your boy is sore
your boy is sore
but uh i'm all right i'm all right man
again our plans do four to six of them
uh this year all over not just uh
california but all over the next one
might be in california but i'll keep you
guys posted on that so
as far as fight news goes man
um
you know this week's a big week for
thick boy because last week we did the
emergency uh food truck diary with
francis ngano um close with his agent
also pretty close to francis so before
he left town they wanted to come on here
and do a food truck uh it's tough to get
a food truck about a 12-hour notice what
we learned
uh so we picked up some of my favorite
uh
hot uh nashville chicken sandwiches and
uh i picked them up and uh we got him
out of my car
and then sat down and did the interview
i think you guys would dig it i think
you guys will dig it that drops i think
where we do it dropping that wednesday
case
yeah i think tentatively it's gonna be
wednesday uh with francis de gano and uh
yeah i love france man i root for him
like i told you guys i i think uh he's
the outlier who can make the change for
what the fighters are looking for you're
talking about a guy who bet on himself
against all odds and went into this
fight with so much pressure and one leg
just the mental capacity it took for him
to overcome and change his complete game
plan from a striker to a grappler and
get it done is legendary man i know for
a lot of you was in the most
entertaining fight i don't give a [ __ ]
about any of that for that guy to have a
blown out mcl and you know acl
compromised and still found a way to get
this done when all the odds were against
him how can he not [ __ ] with that insane
one of the best performances of all time
we talk about you know all the things
that were going against him and the the
company going against them and dana not
putting the belt around his waist and uh
just my hats off to him and i told him
this on food truck how proud of him i am
and i i just i [ __ ] with him man i do
i really do i love him i love his team
markell's agent for
you know what he's trying to accomplish
man what he's trying to do for his
client uh he's taking a lot of heat for
it he's taking a lot of heat for it man
so um you need a strong agent you need
an outlier and both those guys are
outliers and i think uh you know there
is a huge
huge uh
pot of gold at the end of this shitty
shitty rainbow for them but it's there
man it's their entice and fury and um my
hope for them i said this on food truck
when you guys watch my hope for them is
they figure it out with ufc and the ufc
realizes what they have and they make it
right and they're in cahoots with him
when he fights tyson fury because that's
happening
that is happening that is i guarantee it
my last bottom dollar that fight will
happen but i want to happen with the ufc
i want them to be partnered because
there's no better marketing machine than
the ufc nobody does it better than the
ufc so
um
i hope it happens
but i i will say this when the interview
got done
uh your boy was sad because talking to
both of them they're not even close to
figuring it out they're not even close
and it breaks my heart i think there's
egos involved with all of this which
there shouldn't be when you're talking
about a man's career i think
you know remember francis is represented
by ca creative artist agency and
dana white and ufc is owned and
represented by wme
you're talking about the new york
yankees and boston red sox
and they have to come to common ground
and figure it out to for the fighter not
egos not how much you know so uh there's
obviously a conflict of interest
interest there's the first time a guy's
going against the ufc and has reputation
with caa there's a there's so much going
on to untangle behind you know behind
the camera behind everything going on
um
there's a lot of smart people
on the ufc side there's a lot of smart
people on france's side and i just hope
that egos don't ruin
what could be possibly the greatest
um
the greatest outcome for francis and
ghana because that's what we want here
that's what we want so i really hope it
happens man but i'm not gonna lie to you
guys after that food truck i was
depressed
because that's what i want for him you
know that's what i want for him
and i i realize france is not a car guy
and i should have known that um
of course not car guy when he was
growing up he didn't give a [ __ ] about
cars he was trying to escape poverty and
um get his freaking career on track and
that's why he was arrested seven times
trying to flee you know um africa and
all that [ __ ] so of course you don't
give a [ __ ] about cars and when we're uh
doing the food truck we you know it's my
ferrari and i go dude hopefully you can
afford like eight of these with your
next contract because i'm too small dude
i'm not gonna fit anything i don't care
like all right
i go comfort i know comfort like no
doubt i get that man
but uh
it's a good one man and then uh you know
we do the new show the classic cobb ass
fight companions last week's just aired
and that was with sugar
shawn o'malley watching his most
important fights
and uh it's just a fun thing to do with
the fighters and you're talking about
historical moments in their career that
got them to where they're at and you
know those are short form 20 30 minutes
and for francis
you know most fights are a minute long
so it might be the shortest one i don't
know how short it is maybe 20 minutes
but we go over some of his big fights
who sit down that'll come out uh
probably next week um
but it's just interesting to see you
know
i i
i don't wanna say i critiqued him but i
was saying man he just you know
bart simpson that when you know him and
lisa finally spins his arms around and
tries to hit lisa
and i said that's what he did against uh
rosenstroke and he corrected me he's
like no no you gotta realize when i'm
rushing in you'll see here he hits me
behind the air so it looks like i'm
flailing but i'm actually throwing a
combination because my equilibrium is
off i'm losing my balance so it looks
like i'm just wailing these punches but
in my mind like the my motor instincts
i'm still carrying through with the
combo but it looks like i'm just winging
punches i'm not i get clipped behind the
ear and we i go pause it we go back and
oh [ __ ] you did yes yeah people don't
see that man he goes i i got clips from
my glory room's off and i'm just i'm
still throwing the combo but i'm off so
it looks all wild it's not wild that was
all calculating
good to know
and he talks about you know stipe and
you know
losing that first fight and going to the
second one and how stipe thought he was
gonna do this but he decided to fight
you know more strategic and
he i thought the thing too that you know
made my heart happy was he talks about
how tough stipe is and just how exactly
how much respect he has for stephen that
in that second fight he went in going
this guy can eat your bombs this this
this guy isn't going to go away so you
got to be calculated you got to be smart
you got to be cerebral you need a big
high fight iq here you're not going to
get him out of here with one punch he's
too tough and i says it fair to say he's
the toughest ufc fighter ever in france
goes i think so
so it's pretty cool man it's really
really cool how much respect he gives to
stipe so shout out to steve a man
because people you know forget about
that guy i think i'm on the greatest
heavyweights to ever do it if not the
greatest heavyweight to ever do it so
shout out to stipe but that francis food
truck will drop uh i assume this
wednesday if not wednesday definitely
thursday we usually don't drop big
things on friday so it's either
wednesday or thursday this week all new
food truck with francis and gano the
baddest [ __ ] on the planet and
then uh we got a lot going on man
think boy is ramping up we're roaring
uh for the super cast and the thick boy
channel we're bringing back cats after
dark with nick
chin chappelle
um cat so that's coming back on the
think boy channel also that the a new
version of that's coming out on the
super cast if you're gonna check out the
super cast ad free new content more
shows all ad-free everything i do
include fire in the kid all the thick
boy stuff ad-free go to
thickboy.supercast.com
for all that stuff and again i just i
can't thank the fans enough for the love
and support when i showed up at that
tough mudder to be honest with you guys
i thought 20 people would sign up 20
outliers would sign up again it's not
that cheap talking about [ __ ] 15k a
little under 10 miles
mud freezing i figured 20 people would
show up when they told me 400 they told
me the night before they go you have 400
people use the code thick i went what
what wow
and i just
never felt so much love man and then
we're all run together doing it
ourselves man it's [ __ ] inspiring i
get inspiration from you guys
um and all the love we got on thick boy
we're at a damn near 120 000 subscribers
and really we starting [ __ ] gent we
started in january dude i almost had 120
000 subscribers youtube's tough it's not
like social media man to get subscribed
it's [ __ ] tough it is and we're doing
the goddamn thing man and it's all
funded from your boy here there's no
major network carrying this thing
anymore it's all my vision my team's
vision casey chin mike kyle
small crew man knocking this [ __ ] out
giving you the content that you want and
uh
we're just getting started man we're in
january almost 120 000 subscribers some
of the fight companions over a million
views you know what i'm saying that that
episode we dropped with sugar shawn
o'malley
brand new show
classic fight campaign brand new show
over [ __ ] 120 000 views just on
youtube alone and we're audi we're
really audio driven businessman so the
the video is just a bonus for us
so the video's popping you know the
audio is always crushing and i can't
thank you guys enough man um let's get
into the fights and we got so much
cooler [ __ ] coming out man i'm just i'm
stoked i'm [ __ ] stoked let's take a
little break from me ranting about the
mma world because guess what man we're
busy out there maybe you're a dad maybe
you're a businessman business lady
you're a mom or you're just busy in
general man you got back-to-back
meetings you got errands run you got
chores the house is a mess you're like
man i need food though how many dinner
for the fam or my friends you got
friends coming over you're not trying to
cook let my friends at doordash help you
out man you can get dinner household
essentials everything on your grocery
list delivered
check it out get rid of the stress
doordash takes care of all that stuff
for you man they take care of all of it
all right what do you want to eat
maybe you want your home-cooked favorite
but you don't feel like going to the
store again you want to deal with all
that so doordash connects you with
everything you want whenever you want it
however you want it because time to get
back out there but you're like you know
what i'm not ready to do that i'm not
ready i'm not ready well with doordash
you don't have to worry about any of
that let doordash take all the stress
out of getting great food grocery
essentials whatever you need for the
crib doordash will
do the dirty work for you get what you
want to eat right now right to your door
with doordash along with restaurants you
love you can now get groceries other
essential items i got a toothbrush the
other day that's how busy i got a
toothbrush that's right to keep these
things somewhat beige from all the
coffee
uh you know you're with your girl maybe
you're you're on season seven of dexter
or you're watching freaking married at
first sight whatever it is you're like
man i gotta crave them for ice cream so
you order a sunday and cheat on your
diet with extra caramel your boy did
that with doordash you get everything
you want on one freaking app ordering's
easy you order your items they can be
left safely outside your house all right
whatever you want man for a limited time
the listeners and viewers of the shop
show you can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app enter the code shop show that's
s-c-h-a-u-b show all right that's 25 off
up to 10 value and zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store enter the
code shop show don't forget that's code
shop show sch aub show for 25 your first
order with doordass subject to change
terms apply oh my word
the moment we've been waiting for is
here man we're talking about that super
bowl all right in honor of the big game
my rams versus the cincinnati bengals
draft king sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of super ball 56
is giving new customers 56 one odds on
either team bet just five dollars and
get 280 in free bets if your team wins
draftkings sportsbook is now live in new
york big deal meaning you can bet from
almost a third of the country live in
new york kids it's a big market big deal
for my friends at draftkings if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet play draftkings daily fantasy
football contest for super bowl 56 new
customers get
a free shot at one million dollar in top
prize with the first deposit download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
use the promo code shop show and get
fifty six to one odds on either team bet
just five dollars and get 280 in free
bets if your team wins that's promo code
shop show sch a b show at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports playing
partner the nfl and super bowl 56.
you got to be 21 or older minimum age
and location requirements vary by
jurisdictions see draftkings.com
sportsbook for a full list of
requirements in state specific
responsible gaming resources voidware
prohibited gambling problem call 100
gambler in tennessee call or text
tennessee redline 1-800-889-9789
in connecticut call
york call 888-789-7777 seven seven eight
h-o-p-e-n-y or text
h-o-p-e-n-y
four six seven three six nine if you're
still listening download the draftking
sports app bet on the big super ball use
the promo code shop show
so uh as far as fights go
shout out to khabib man khabib put on uh
his first north america uh eagle
fighting championship
um
the tyrone spang kiritana of one could
have told you i didn't like the fight
for splunk even though he's a wizard on
his feet
dude kirtanov is a monster
grappler too and splunk coming back from
the leg injury so
yeah man it's kind of an ass whooping uh
shut up my boy rashad evans for taking
that much time off getting it done you
know what i'm saying like such a beast
absolutely love rashad another one we
need to get on food truck casey he's a
very close friend i should probably text
him uh and then rape nothing makes me
more happy than when ray borg wins you
guys know the history of ray borg and
his son having the extra fluid on the
brain that's not something
that's not a disease or that's not an
illness that just gets fixed that's
something he's always going to deal with
you guys know my history with ray borg
and his son and um i don't know ray
we've only tweeted or dm'd or uh texts
here and there um but i root for that
guy harder than anybody out there man so
hopefully he had a nice payday hope he's
chilling with his son right now
listening to this and giving him a big
hug and a kiss from me man um john
howard's back you know he lost i heard
the name john doomsday howard [ __ ]
forever
but i love what uh khabib's doing man
i love and i hope it went well for him i
really do hope it went well for him uh
you don't have any ufc this weekend it's
some bellator i dude for [ __ ] brian
bader to beat
homeboy yeah valentine is not
such a goddamn savage dude
but i think was was bader or was jack
uh our first food truck guest i think it
was ryan bader
they might have been the same day or one
one day apart but they were some of our
first guests
on the food truck yeah with showtime
i can go around showtime pretty sure it
might have been ryan bader might have
been the first one
that was at the very like three years
ago
quite possibly it's either that one or
jack jack
jack the
uh if you type in jack um
let's just do that the bellator dude
john hager jason that's three years ago
too
look at sugar shawn the new one 12 days
old one set 200 000 son
yeah man oh yeah that stuff makes me
happy
same
uh ryan bader got it done shout out to
ryan bader man what a [ __ ] beast have
your heavyweight champ heavyweight champ
uh ben henderson got it done a split
decision
um yeah you know bellator is doing the
goddamn thing man
it's a slow week for fight you gotta you
had a fight night this week uh when my i
think top five most entertaining
fighters on the fc roster um
sean strickland he's an absolute madman
love his interviews love his fires from
the [ __ ] hip good or bad you can get
how he feels and i [ __ ] with that
especially in this day of censorship and
you know cancel culture i think sean
strickland's an outlier there man and i
root for guys like that he has a tough
task and jack herm hermansen very tough
the joker is no joke um
but i i do think sean strickland will
get it done i'm rooting for sean
strickland since he moved to
middleweight man he's on a [ __ ] tear
he's a tough guy to deal with very tough
guy to deal with
he's just again beating your eye halls
no punk jock goes no punk brendan
allen's no punk you know so since we
turned to middleweight he's undefeated
and in this return man he's won five in
a row and um i'm i'm hoping he gets this
one done man i really am i think you
will i think you will he should the odds
have them get it done
but again they're just edging us to the
february 12th ufc you know how it goes
man they're aginus the february 12th
one's good
man do we have a fun fight campaign for
that i got a big special guess big pun
intended as well
my boy jelly roll is coming up oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] love love
jayla roll's interesting because
he's not he reminds me of joey diaz
where
you know he's not a big text guy he's
more of a call and talk guy so
i text he sometimes sometimes i just
can't call her when i get off work i
talk for a living so i don't want to
call or talk to people so i'll just text
him
so i text him probably he probably texts
me
three months ago four months ago one of
the first fight commands goes dude it
looks so much [ __ ] fun i want in
that's all right cool man this is three
four months goes uh how's february sound
yep you're on for february
a week i was like oh [ __ ] i told uh
jelly i wonder if he's serious so i text
him like yo man how seriously about this
fight companion goes i'm in okay cool
i'll make the assets called ruben our
[ __ ] brilliant graphic guy makes
assets
um sent them that things but all right
starts it i haven't heard back he'll
show up
let's show him he's a tricky one i know
i remember yeah he's a tricky one show
up he better show up
show up yeah now that's february 12th i
think and then the super bowl's february
13th
you know
super balls here in uh california right
here in l.a man
let's see
yeah it's february 12th
super balls february [ __ ]
13th
busy busy
busy week yep
busy week man
yeah i loved it and also i need a
drinking partner man you know what i'm
saying he's the best yeah he's the best
the best partner
he got everybody hammered won't we're
nasty even cat everyone it got cat with
you yeah yeah everybody yeah and the
manager shout out to the manager lucy if
zany's out there in nashville she goes
it's so interesting she was like it was
like
jelly roll was the sun and you guys are
just planets i know orbiting around and
while he's giving you drinks telling
stories tell everybody he's the best
storyteller he's so many fun stories his
life he's such a great dude
i [ __ ] love jelly roll man
you know those people you're just
instant friends that's jelly roll me and
him just instantly
right off the bat friends just that's my
boy man that's my [ __ ] guy i [ __ ]
love jelly roll and his music career
popping another guy banked on himself
did all himself now all the record
labels coming after him his shows are
nuts
like lots and tons of people not so yeah
he's getting into podcasting more he's
doing a lot more podcasting yep
he's been on a bunch with my busting one
of the boys bros you know
so yeah i love jelly roll so hopefully
he comes because i need a drinking
partner
he's coming he's coming yeah he's coming
what else you got dude uh just quick
ones as a recap on these fights so since
ryan bader defeated moldovsky he's gonna
have a rematch with chet congo remember
the first time they fought that that i
poked that we all thought was kind of
like we didn't really 100 believe it
well they're gonna have their rematch
may 6th in paris
and benson henderson great win for him
as well
so
he's not having a 20 fight on beacon on
beaten streak yeah like that's no
a lot of these fights said the the
winners were like not the favorite yeah
yeah no hell no bader was their favorite
and ben henderson was a favorite ben
hashan such a great dude yeah such a
beast of a dad kids are [ __ ] gorgeous
it's going to have kids man just root
for other dads i know i hear you
cooper cup has kids
you know do the cooper cup thing when
you start talking about it i didn't know
who he was and then i see him popping up
everywhere now
dude he led us to the super bowl
one of the greatest seasons ever
ever dude he shows up man
unstoppable had one drop yesterday
whatever people make mistakes one is the
game
cool
uh so ben henderson he that was his last
fight on the bellator contract i believe
and then now so scott coker is like you
know if he wants to bounce it's all good
he's done everything but then ben kind
of hinted that either he's going to
retire or possibly go with eagle fc he
was talking it could be
i'd be cool if ben goes with eagle fc
and becomes a world champion there and
then like one fight for the title there
gets that belt just you've you know done
everything be cool yeah
but you also as a dad you wanted to stop
and you know smell the roses with the
kids man
okay i was hoping you had this this is
hilarious go ahead
go ahead well you mentioned this so i
finally spoke up about why he didn't put
the belt on francis he said he was
dealing with stuff backstage
yeah and my theory on this okay so this
is what dana said so uh during a fan q a
session on svm plus wednesday
he was i wasn't out there for the main
event i actually walked out of the arena
right after the coming event because
there was stuff going on backstage i was
dealing with
but it doesn't say what he's dealing
with right for anybody to think that i
was showing any type of respect towards
francis you were i saw friends saw weak
you idiots i shook his hand i said hi to
him i was out there for the stare downs
the whole thing you weren't there for
the most important thing though dana for
anybody to think there was some type of
disrespect shown towards france i wasn't
out there for michael bisping versus
rockhold she's like see i've done it
before
um because i was doing some stuff this i
spent for the back i didn't even have my
jacket i only had my shirt on to go out
there put the belt on bisping but i
couldn't make it out there to put the
belt on francis the only thing one time
i walked out a fight and i made it very
clear show up to the press conference
said this sick exactly why i left i was
an abu dhabi with anderson silva it was
the dame in my fight so there's the
answer i don't know if somebody asked
that but somebody wanted to there you go
uh it was an absolute honor receiving
the belt from uh mick mcmaniard uh
france wrote can be a better person i
love this man for sure
bro i don't care about that i'm happy
that's all that matters yeah i'm with
francis on this here's the thing with
dana so
what i think happened is um
you know there's some stuff that went on
before the week of the fight there's
some stuff that went on between uh dana
and francis representation and clearly
um any time a fighter especially a
france magnitude fights back into the
scenes very uh
out about it it creates um animosity for
dana and the fighter so it's awkward
it's awkward for him it's awkward for
his representation the ufc hates
france's reputation because they don't
play the same game everybody else is
because everybody else for the most part
are sheeps because wm wme represents the
ufc dana white right they
it's a conflict of interest to the
fullest extent so they hate that francis
isn't going uh when they say jump he's
asking how high he's when the only
outliers you ask all right how high i'll
jump but how high do i need to jump
so i think this animosity led up to the
fight
and they were banking and
also the ufc brass dana especially knew
that francis had one leg go in this
fight
he was not expected to win this fight
so they thought they had him dead to
rights they thought this was over this
will make all this go away france can be
forced to sign with us
you don't know francis ingano you don't
know that this ain't [ __ ] compared to
what he's dealt with his entire life
mentally you have no idea how strong
francis is he figures out how to get
done even on one leg wins
and it and it puts all the chips in
france's corner all the chips
it's dana's ego it's dana's ego that
it's his one
downfall man it's just
his one downfall and i said this last
week on the show i said to francis on
food truck or maybe the classified
companion
i can't believe he doesn't have someone
around his team
that when this was going on when france
is going to win the fight and dana had
to sprint to the back to deal with
issues during the biggest moment of the
night
and issues they don't tell us about
right there could have been a bigger
issue than putting a belt on francis
everybody in that arena knows what it
will look like if dana doesn't put the
belt on francis right
i can't believe there's not someone in
his circle whether it's a co-worker an
assistant
a colleague a peer that goes hey man
you've won bub you've won dude you've
won you have 500 million in the bank
all you got to do let's not create this
narrative it's gonna make you look
really bad it is to make you look bad if
you don't put the belt on france you
look like a sore loser
put the belt on him let's be
professional and then we'll deal with
the x's and o's and the numbers after
the fact but he's deserved this he
deserves this and all this does is give
him more power in negotiations the way
you're treating him it's not a good look
man just be cool also you've won you
have 500 million the bank dude francis
has nothing i know you're paying 650 000
after taxes
paying the traders it's nothing for him
let's not let's not stir the pot man
you've won and also remember just go put
the belt on him because then there's no
story here and helps us in negotiations
after this and also remember you have
500 million dollars in the bank dude
right you have 500 million dollars a mic
you're you're
kids kids kids kids kids you got
generational wealth francis does not
france can't take
two years off and continue to live a
good life he has to fight he's a cage
fighter
you remember dana i'd whisper into the
remember dude she put the bell on him so
it doesn't create all this chaos and
make you look like an [ __ ] and puts
more people in france's corner put the
belt on and remember dude you have 500
million in the bank you've won and we
still jump on your private jet what what
house you want to go to dude you want to
go to your miami house we're going to
the vegas house you want to go to the
newport house where you montana new york
we have all the we go to brazil your
house there what do you want to do dude
you've won there's no reason to act like
this
but
part of the reason what makes dana white
great is also his biggest liability and
that's his ego and the ego got the best
of them and he was a sore loser no i'm
not doing this and then ran to the back
okay cool
well
there's one person that can control dana
white there's one person his name's arya
emanuel he's the owner of wme and when
he says jump he's the only guy on the
planet dana goes how high sir he's the
only guy
i'm willing to bet
that somebody in that powerful circle
when that got done called and went what
the [ __ ] are you doing what are you
doing
what are you doing are you out of your
mind we're in negotiation with this guy
this is the one guy
that might make a change for the
fighters do you realize what you're
doing and you're just adding fuel to the
[ __ ] fireman and why
because he bet on himself when he won on
one [ __ ] leg are you out of your mind
you're gonna make this right
the next time somebody asks you about
this you better come up with something
where you don't look like a complete
[ __ ]
and what happened
oh no i love francis i actually i was
dealing with something in the back it's
happened before and uh no i mean france
was cool all week i was at the stare
down
okay
i guarantee you
the guys that call the shots now the ufc
sold
ain't they're not playing that game
you're adding more fuel to the [ __ ]
fire
you're not helping this thing out this
does not help negotiations
and they've done everything
if you look at they've done everything
i've talked off camera with people on
france's team
they've done everything in their power
to try and take the power away from
francis and ghana they can't stand that
this man has the power over them they
can't stand he's the face of the
heavyweight division they can't stand
that he banked himself with one leg and
he shouldn't be here and he still
[ __ ] won they can't stand
that now he's taught now he's getting
even bigger he's getting even louder
they can't stand it he's
represented by ca they hate that but
he's continue
they don't realize what i'm telling you
man they don't realize what they're
dealing with you're talking about a
complete [ __ ] outlier with the mental
strength of a [ __ ] special forces
soldier that's gone through [ __ ] that
you can't even imagine dana you can't
even [ __ ] fathom who you're [ __ ]
with
oh on top of that mental strength
he has the body of a [ __ ] x-men and
he's the hardest hitter to ever walk
through that god damn cage
and you wanna you think you're gonna
break that guy you think you can
disrespect that guy not put the belt on
him are you out of your goddamn mind
and this isn't a [ __ ] on dana episode at
all i'm a fan i don't think the ufc
would have got where they've where
they've gotten without dana's vision his
work ethic his ego
again that ego is his biggest
biggest
biggest achilles heel on him it's
trouble man
but what happened i told i [ __ ] told
you guys so that our emanuel went what
are you doing dude you've just given
them even more [ __ ] fuel by not
putting the bell on and why
what are you doing
and now we're seeing it oh no no no i
didn't disrespect him i i had to you you
could so you had to write something was
so important hey you can't tell us
something was so important you have to
rush to the back
you're not helping francis
look at the star power on that card
let's talk about that what about the
star power on that card was it the was
it a stat card for you guys was there
not complaints about the card
oh well we put the flyweight
championship on there you know the
flyweights don't bring massive views
so let's talk about that why would you
put
and this in disrespect any of the fires
on them i'm just talking about it's very
black and white why was the rest of the
car no star power
anyone know why
well in negotiations
what they're going to do with france is
i put this sold
between three to four hundred thousand
pay-per-views
which isn't bad they need 300k to which
they think uh to get their nut back
right
so and you look at the pay structures
they made all the money in the world
this card there's no star power on it
so
by stacking
a card you're you you can't really
figure out who
you can credit the main event because
they were the main event that's who we
uh put on the marketing bill and that's
the headliners and they get a
pay-per-view point and they're gonna
make more money
sure but when the card's not when you
look at ufc 100 ufc 200 you look at some
of these
pay-per-views coming up they're all more
stacked than this one
that was a complete strategic business
move by the ufc and the brass of the ufc
to undermine francis and ganu because
it's francis the biggest name in america
as far as pay-per-view goes no he's been
out for a while cyril gone not his star
yet he's just not a star yet so they put
flyweights on there so they don't draw
too much attention to it they look at
the rest of the card
i don't think any of those guys have
ever really no one else has ever been a
headliner no one else is really a star
pay-per-view driven fighter
they do that so now
when ca sits down with wme and
negotiates a deal for francis what's
fair then go
last fight only did three hundred
thousand man
it's not great
you don't deserve the whatever money
you're asking for it's not an obscene
amount of money it's what's right if he
if he asks for what's
exactly what he's due it'd be an obscene
amount of money but we can't even play
that game he's trying to get somewhat
higher
so there's a reason why that
pay-per-view as far as um pay-per-view
star power
it wasn't on there because now it's
again it's another thing
to go against francis and ghana it's a
[ __ ] shame
it's a [ __ ] shame because remember
too
that you know him giving pay-per-view
points it lowers everything and you see
they don't care if they sell
200 300 000 more paid views on this one
or the next one or the next one or the
next one they're gonna get theirs the
house always wins
and that's why i tell you guys
i don't need you to be a franciscano fan
maybe you don't like something that he
does or maybe you don't like this or
that i don't care about any of that i
told you go on this fight even if you're
[ __ ] from france and you went to a
[ __ ] middle school cyril gone if they
have middle school and french i don't
know how it works out there but even if
that's your if you if that was your
[ __ ] neighbor you should root for
francis in this fight sarah will be
champion eventually
but right now what francis is doing has
never been done before
and he can change the game for everybody
on that roster
it's historic man
i can't emphasize that enough you want
this guy to win you've all had shitty
bosses out there we've all worked for
the man it [ __ ] sucks and now you got
a guy i told you with a special forces
[ __ ] mindset in the body of an x-men
and he's trying to make the change
he's then you need someone of that
magnitude to make the change he's the
only guy
car ain't the guy anymore
connor's set
his path has been set he has too much
money to make the change he's not his
prime anymore that's over khabib's
retired that's over you have nobody else
like francis you have your heavyweight
champ of the world talking about where's
our health care where's our fighter pay
and then he beats the guy that they
thought was going to beat him on one
[ __ ] leg
now he's saying
what's up now they've stacked everything
against them they even put the belt
around them
think about it it's clear the writings
on the [ __ ] wall shitty pay-per-view
so he has no negotiating power didn't
put the belt on him made him sit out for
out fought once a year barely
they've done everything in their power
to get this man to lose
but they've never ever dealt with a
[ __ ] animal like francis ingano ever
and his team shout to markel they've
never dealt with anything
than these two [ __ ] men who have the
vision that they have
and there's a board meeting today with
with the [ __ ] ufc
i just for the life of me i can't figure
out hopefully arya man was in that
[ __ ] meeting because we got to get
dana's ego out of this one
and we need dana we need him on board to
get this deal done he has to he's the
only he has to be on board otherwise the
deal doesn't get done
we gotta [ __ ] ca [ __ ] these camps it's
about francis
and even as a businessman
the ufc is going to make more money with
francis gano in the ufc and then helping
promote his fights with tyson fury than
any other scenario that they're going to
figure out
how much money would the ufc make if
they can just
give francis not not what he's do
because you're never going to pay that
i'm just saying a higher guarantee
a fraction of what he's worth
and marking them the same way
how much more money are you going to get
doing that and you get the jon jones
super fight you get at least two tyson
fury collabs how much more money you
miss out on all that
but at the end of the day you know who
misses out the most the fans and you owe
it to the fans
you've increased your pay-per-view price
you force us to buy espn plus
what else do you want man you owe it to
us to put your ego to the side on this
one time dana i [ __ ] beg you man put
the ego to the side and figure this out
with france's team and don't look at
francis as ca versus wme look at it as
[ __ ] a guy who runs the best
biggest baddest
fight league in the world to ever do it
and you're probably the greatest
president of all [ __ ] time man you're
up there with roger goodell i'll give
you that credit man you're the [ __ ]
guy for this one time i beg you man put
your ego to the side and work with
francis team you
you [ __ ] owe it to us the fans
otherwise we miss out on francis jon
jones
that's the only fight i want to see i
want to see nothing else i speak for
millions of people dude
you [ __ ] owe it to us you want that
extra money play ball i'll give you
whatever money you want
whatever you're selling i'll [ __ ] buy
whatever you want man
but this one time i need you put your
ego to the side and look at him like a
[ __ ] human being and get the deal
done because you owe us francis jon
jones you owe us tyson fury francis you
got to be involved in that why won't you
want to be involved with that
you owe it to us do what's right
you've already won dude you've already
won
it doesn't take away from your shine if
you give francis some shine
the only reason we heard his remarkable
story which has been sold to hollywood
his life story has been sold to
hollywood they have seven different
[ __ ] offers from the biggest movie
studios to ever do it
hollywood knows his story the fans are
just getting a story but where did the
story come from
not the ufc
even though you guys are the best in the
world at marketing there's nobody better
you're better than the nfl the nba not
even close kudos to you you have an
amazing staff you guys are the best
i'll give you that
but you've never told you never gave
francis a fair shot we've never heard
his story
never
we had he had to go on joe rogan to hear
the whole story
rogan did that ufc didn't book francis
on rogan rogan called france's team
booked that rogan books himself
if he saw his apology today
apology i wouldn't call an apology i
would call it a uh
an informational
video a nine minute video on instagram
from his side of things
he'd says i book it all myself yeah
you'll see him book that and that's how
we got france's story on the biggest
show in the world
that's not ufc's doing
why not why not be cool man for once be
cool you guys have one man
and if you're worried about other
fighters following france's footsteps
i get that you don't want to set you
know presidents where
other every guy's doing this you're not
prince is an outlier he's a once in a
[ __ ] lifetime fighter man and if you
[ __ ] him over you're gonna regret it
it's gonna be the biggest regret you've
ever had
ever
ever ever you know how historic it's
gonna be for francis for steison fury
you guys don't be involved in that
i know espn page or not and you guys get
all the money from them i get it man
but you guys know what's right i know
ari emanuel knows what's right too and
he's the one that made you apologize for
doing this and he's the one that when
you guys when he tells you to jump you
ask how high ari
he's and he's not from the fight world
he's not from this world he's from the
business world and that's why he's
trying to make you make this right
figure it out guys
figure it out
you got to figure it out
have to
you just have to i beg you guys again
you want to charge more money charge all
these pay-per-views put on pay-per-view
once a once a month then we got paid for
[ __ ] espn plus do all that stuff i
get all of it
do what's right imagine if any other
sport treated us like this treat the
fans like this
imagine if because georgia was
represented by somebody else
you wouldn't let them play in the
national championship you let them go
play elsewhere because you didn't like
the representation you didn't want to
sit in the same room as them
imagine the uproar imagine how furious
fans would be
it'd be insane
be insane
but our audience the fighter is so
custom just taking it
taking it and shutting up because we
have no control over it for the first
time
francis has all the control and you guys
can't afford to miss out on a francis
renewed contract again he's not asking
for 10 20 million
he'll make that generational money he'll
make that in the tyson fury fight
so just play ball don't get in the way
help him out
because again nobody's better at marking
nobody's better negotiation he's gonna
have to have somebody a big dog
negotiate that contract against tyson
fury
and the one shot the small chance he
knocks tyson fury out
how great does that make the ufc look
that your heavyweight champ knocked out
the best heavyweight of all time
i'll debate you all day on tyson fear
being in the heavyweight jam all the
time by by the way the best i'll i'll
argue that all day give me who you
think's better enticing fury
skill wise defense footwork his size
yeah he's not a knockout artist but as
far as fundamentally get the [ __ ] out of
my face there's nobody better i was
smoking those old school guys you want
to talk about joe frazier mohammad ali
mike tyson riddick beau likes all the
same size don't have the same footwork
i'll argue that all day and francis and
he can
if he lands that [ __ ] bomb on him and
wins what's that do for this
sport of the ufc
what if he went unsigned with bellator
or ryzen or one championship well then
they get all the accolades
also if you don't sign them and say john
fights stephen which i think will happen
this year because france is out with the
knee
are they really the champ because the
the the guy that i know is the champ
isn't fighting so you have a fake champ
and he that's forever and beyond his
record
so there's so it's a butterfly effect
there's me some the downside to not
playing ball and being cool with francis
the downside is so much bigger than the
upside it's not even close man
and i know you guys know this it's just
the goddamn egos in the way
unreal
that's my ranch and
that's a good rant though
long and good
okay you mentioned francis's knee so
markelle martin said it was gonna be uh
nine to ten month recovery time and it
starts i guess the surgery is gonna be
in march so it'll be like all year
basically
what's great about the these knee
surgeries with science and
you know technology now is that used to
be a career ender you know and now
there's guys in the nfl who have an acl
surgery you look at a guy like uh
adrian peterson and there's been a
number of other guys with acls dude in
the early 2000s the 90s you tear icl
you're done
now france bigger batter than ever
i love the guys who go
well i fought with the acl tear i
thought mcl you're not 280 pounds
and you don't just rely on your your
[ __ ]
boxing to win fights
if you're a lighter guy you're like well
i had a strained acl i don't get
you don't you know what francis told me
i said he looked in shape he looks thin
though right your boy is in shape too
and he goes that's how it started goes
man you're in shape but yeah i'm on this
carnivore man i'm getting more australia
to do this thick mudder race and i go
how much do you weigh he's like i'm
about 268 270 right now
the agent markell goes tell him what you
walk around at when you're out of camp
he said 290
shredded
290.
now if you think if you're a 150 500 785
125 115 pound fighter if you think your
acl is more important in a fight than a
man that walks around 290 pounds and all
he relies on is power from that [ __ ]
knee
to win fight so he can gain traction and
get his hips and
throw a [ __ ] punch
if you think you comparing your
injury to his is any remotely facet
you stupid how about that
what else you got
all right and that doctor who's doing it
did gsps co i think he worked on kobe
he's worked on everybody man great
doctor
he's the doctor yeah
uh so uh what do you think of this this
is kevin lee's statement on why he was
basically let go
is because i've seen it okay
this is danny segura he's writing for
mma junkie he's been with him in joking
for a while really i love dancing he's
great yeah monster he does spanish stuff
like this
wish we give him over to thick boy
come on bye mm-hmm
no i mean work for us yeah yeah that's
something come on food truck yes
uh so this is kevin talking yeah to say
i was surprised no not really i know the
back end and all that stuff goes behind
closed doors they really showed me no
respect towards the end i feel like i
ate a lot of the flak for guys like
franciano and his situation with them
they used me as kind of like a pawn and
a scapegoat and really i hope other
fighters kind of see that that's why
they do that's what they do to you they
don't like the way negotiations was
handled with francis so they took it out
on me to kind of show ca a lesson kevin
kevin lee's a ca guy yeah
remember marcelo brought him in for
free
yeah but i think in the end we're going
to show you show that you can't
necessarily treat people like this and
there's many other ways to make money
and kind of outshine them
so we're going to beat them one way or
another see i i i don't like the
narrative of i'm gonna leave the ufc and
that's how we're gonna beat them
you've already lost once you exit the
ufc
the way you beat them
is even though they're doing all this
terrible [ __ ] to you
you figure out a way and this is his
ca's representation francis's
representation you figure out a way to
the way to beat them is by getting a
good contract yourself and continue to
be with them because once you're out
you're out man but i think his point is
they took it on on him to show francis
and c.a a lesson remember because he he
was also on like a two fight losing
skill dude he was one out of four yeah
he was not so it's it's a it's a stretch
you guys i i don't think him being
represented by ca helped i'll give him
that that ain't the reason you got yeah
one of those five yeah you know
now if you didn't have the ca
representation and the france
association all that would they have
played ball with them i don't think so
one of four you know it's getting pretty
big paydays
but the narrative that oh the way we
beat them is by leaving the ufc no
you're beating yourself when you do that
that's like that's like antonio brown or
you know tom brady going forget the nfl
man i'm gonna go over the cfl i'm gonna
go play whatever that they have that new
[ __ ] league that nobody's gonna watch
except the other rocks all about um i'm
gonna show the nfl i'm gonna go to the
cfl
okay
yeah it's more money man
but you're not playing at the highest
level yeah
and once you do that you're in obscurity
and nobody really cares
yep
okay jeremy stevens after 34 fights with
ufc he's now no longer with them hall of
famer man
hall of famer
uh leaves a kind of six fight win this
skid
you know what i'm saying so even hit me
like yeah because i'm he's not let's say
he's like i'm i'm resident
represented by ca the reason they let me
go is because you know i'm with ca or
you lost your last six fights yeah
for kevin's like where you lost you know
you lost four you're one out of your
last five dude
yeah um but he's always been exciting i
love germany stevens holds the record
for fourth most appearance in the ufc 34
bouts
um six and a half hours spent in the
action he also ranks top five with the
most decision win
uh 18 knock downs seven fighter nights
but he had a hall of famer
key wins over dos sanjos uh gilbert
melendez uh hannah brown adam brown cole
miller darren elkins marcus davis
yeah but he did have a skid yeah give me
your goddamn gold jacket and according
to aaron hewani jeremy stevens is
basically signed or going to sign with
pfl let's go off and just keep fighting
yeah that's great feels great
uh to compete in their 2022 lightweight
tournament yeah he's a fan favorite for
sure
um here's a quick one come on usman said
that he was actually considering
not just jumping one eight not just
going to 185 but jumping 185 to fight
young black voice that's a terrible idea
that's an absolute terrible idea he is
not built for that
izzy's way bigger than camaro's
not a big man
205 would have been a [ __ ] nightmare
you know yawns are big people get it
twisted man they think go 205. young's
really about 240 and he beat israel he's
205 about three times a year the rest is
about 240. he beat izzy
and and then you know this
when you're talking about
size
you know size only matters
if you're talking you know if kamar was
going to fight a guy who had no skill
but when camaro comes in let's say it
comes at 180 pounds
and
you know yon walks in right i'd say to
around two
220-ish
but yan
has there's certain things he does
better than tomorrow so when you're
talking about size and skills is always
going to be under size and skill always
bar none always this would be a terrible
idea
what's interesting too on food i don't
give away too much the food truck but
francis said when he blew out his knee
he's like three or four weeks out from
the fight his entire team said all right
there's too much on the line let's not
do this
so he called camaro who's very close
with and camaro talked about all the
times he's fought for world titles
having injuries and didn't spar and
still mentally was able to get together
and win the fights kamal was like if he
can do it i can do this i'm fighting he
got the inspiration from camaro so shout
out to tomorrow yeah how much of a
badass kamar who's been meant i heard he
can't even walk normally no his knees
are like he can't do road work yeah
there's there's some camps that he's you
know the kobe comington fights all you
know the the hoary mazda dolls you
didn't spar at all dude
crazy nuts nothing about francis never
been in that situation before all the
[ __ ] chips are stacked against them
one leg find a guy who moves like a
[ __ ]
matrix character
and you figure out a way to still beat
him
through grappling
nutsos take a page straight off camaro
usman's book
shout out to spin man for sure
all right so this is uh dana white just
teasing that they're working on uh tony
ferguson versus michael chandler i love
that
i love that
i also mentioned this too that they
he said nothing's signed yet but they're
they're still working on it and then i
guess patty pimblett was rumored to
fight jared gordon but now he's fighting
someone else on that england card that's
a fight yeah that's a great card yeah
um did they figure out how to put up for
a different tale yet i'm sure he's on
that card right or no i don't think so
i figured i'm not saying he is i mean it
makes sense if he's on that card yeah
he's a pay-per-view fighter though
this is december 6.
see that
says he will headline march 19th but
that was back in the day so i don't know
where he's at
yeah
uriah hall
is that going down that card
i don't know let me see here
it's a great fight if it is i thought
that was the fight wouldn't it it wasn't
called off or something though
in the works yep there you go
september 13th it's a little bit ago
yeah
because right because now had uh tom
aspinall's headlining
isn't he's doing a fight
off that's a fight night but that ufc
london's a fight night okay yeah
yeah yeah you're right
yeah so maybe that's just off you're
right
until it'd be [ __ ] fire on there we
might have to companion for that
i wonder what time it starts press start
super early right be dope though
early fights are great
um this is also
cool
it was supposed to happen regardless but
uh yeah so just engaging versus charles
oliver is that in may or april 274. i
have it here somewhere
may 7th
and it was supposed to take place in
brazil but now
it's shifted so they don't know they
don't know the
venue or location quite yet
great fight yeah
alrighty next one
this is pretty crazy donald cerrone
versus joe lauzon for april 30th i like
it for both of them yeah it's not a
young lion you know trying to rip their
heads off two
legends you know who have had some time
off
obviously i'm rooting for my boy cerrone
there that's great that's fun
and we got a vincente lucky versus blah
mohammed rematch ufc fight night april
16th
lucky won the first one that's just to
clear up you know that division yeah
i know luke wanted the nate diaz fight
and all that but
okay
and we talked about jan blakovich
earlier he's supposed to fight alexander
rakitch but it's being rescheduled now
because
he has an injury that's similar to mine
i think
yeah
in my spine around the neck that makes
the impulsive training with heavy
weights i need to fix that now
oh wow that sounds like a pretty bad
injury yeah you don't want to mess with
that
so that's going to be your schedule
that's a bummer
and this one has been a while since
gunnar nelson that's why he's fighting a
guy named claudio silva
and
that's for that you that london card in
martial
yeah that [ __ ] ufc loaning card is
getting pretty stacked it's march what
i have it right here
what was it 19 yeah 19. is it the 19th
yeah and that will be on early here
i don't think i'm on the road march 19th
my birthday's on the 18th
birthday dude pisces bros
that would be a good
even though because it's not a
pay-per-view it's on his fan so
everybody could watch it and it's a huge
card
i just love and jack shores on there too
our boy jack shaw on there we're all
rooting for him yep dan hooker arnold
allen stack gunner nelson paddy's on
there
then you got aspinall
his first like huge test you beat volkov
it's off the [ __ ] races for tom
you could be the face
3 p.m eastern so that's going to be
super early that's noon here
i love noon
12 p.m eastern
yeah
and we're just chilling home saturday
morning that'd be cool figure that out
yeah if i'm in town plan on it
cool
let's go
oh yeah here so that's why i figured so
yura hal is set uh is set to fight a guy
named andre moon is i didn't know much
about this guy either but i looked up
his record
and he looks pretty much like a killer
too
yeah you remember for that last one the
uc 269
jiu jitsu monster
yeah he submitted [ __ ] jock right for
god's sakes yeah
clearly your eyes gonna keep this on the
feet sex is no dear until fight but
yeah i don't know what's up with duranto
uh so
this is a report that julianna pena and
amanda nunes are they say frontrunners
for coaching the next ultimate fighter
didn't say what it's going to be though
man i feel like the ultimate fighter
that's like
such a waste of time
it's such a waste of time
they should just clap well like you
don't want to [ __ ] up the tuesday night
contenders dana white did which i think
is the best by far you said that forever
yeah yeah by far the best like
competition show and there's the talent
that comes out of there's nuts too and
that's where they're getting the most
their talent now field ultimate fighter
just
no one pays attention it's only spin
plus it's weak now it was very weird
that brian ortega and volkonovsky one it
was just not
nobody watched yeah and like now they're
faking animosity they're faking this
because remember like especially when i
fought on the ultimate fighter like
rashad and rampage generally hated each
other man you didn't need to build any
story lines you didn't need to do this
weird you know i think they had like
cows or some [ __ ]
stealing tires straight up it's like
real world yeah it used to be more fight
and there's real animosity and now it's
like this weird real world thing they're
creating this animosity it's
no the the there's it's not a launching
pad anymore like if i was a manager and
my father got offered the ultimate
fighter contender series we're going
container series all day i bet the views
on contender series is way higher
yeah it's all fights too it's fun
yeah
uh this is a quick boxing one so katie
taylor and amanda serrano you know man
toronto is jake paul's
girl
not girlfriend but you know his boxer
yeah on his on his promotion
um
or whatever his management so katie
taylor and amanda they're considered the
best right now in their division so
they're actually going to fight april
30th that's the baby
msg i'm definitely going for katie
taylor yeah
alrighty
uh this is just a quick one i thought
was interesting so khabib says
uh ufc and bellator better treat their
fighters good because eagle fc is here
bigger bigger organizations like uc
belgium they have to be careful with
their fighters because the eagle fc is
here
of course we're trying to assign good
athletes great athletes and good names
at the same time we're working with
young generation two we have two goals i
just wanted to say be careful they don't
treat
treat good fighters eagle fc is here you
don't think he's throwing shade at it
but
scroll down he goes i understand this
game from the inside i was professional
fighter for last 12 years i have a lot
of fighters that they really want weight
classes like 55 65 75 85.
when i opened the eagle fc i was like
why can't we do this let's build some
new history agree 100
yeah it'd be interesting to see those
weight divisions
now how good like kevin lee will be
diego sanchez you should get young like
stars too to build your
organization
kirby also said he sent uh
i think it's basically a contract to
james
i know that's all that is so we're
talking about khabib's organization
tight move khabib but clearly so he says
we offered him we offer him a contract
um now we're waiting on his answer if he
wants we're here yeah he's not going to
do that but it's great marketing
brilliant top from a contract
and speaking of jake paul apparently he
bought shares in ufc stock or actually
endeavors stock
and then here's his reasoning i'll show
you
i invest in the ufc stock with my
partner to focus on ufc's esg stands
really into fighters who believe vdr can
drive long-term economic value by
increasing ufc fighter pay and providing
them with health care reaching out to
engine number underscore one to partner
on this in denver
endeavor yeah
yeah man say what you want about jake
but he's
by far done the most for fighters than
any fighter not even close in a short
period of time so the shores a lot of
people learning from yeah you can't hate
them for that man hate on for the
youtube [ __ ] or whatever but as far as
doing what's right nobody else is doing
especially to that magnitude so you
gotta give him kudos
definitely all right so i'm not sure if
we can actually air this but
it's interesting enough to play so jake
paul made a music video it's a diss
track to dana white conor mcgregor and
jorge masdon here's the thing too again
it's another ego thing i've seen dana
saying this keeps him you know saying
jake paul's name keeps dana relevant in
the news and he's great at that he's
with the full send boys and all that
[ __ ] so it keeps them relevant with you
know
current uh culture and stuff like that i
get all that but man you play this game
you're not gonna beat these young kids
in this this [ __ ] you're just not when
come social media and youtube that's
their world that's like
you know that's like jake paul having to
run the ufc
you know he can't do it and you can't do
his job so why you want to talk [ __ ] to
this kid this will never end
all jake paul he's just a content
creator before he was a fighter it's
even now he's a content creator so you
give him an inch and you allow him he
needs content he needs content that's
how he pays his bills
so you're just you're just [ __ ] with
the wrong person it will never stop
they're always he's always going to win
this side of things always yeah i have a
feeling dana white's just going to just
stop saying stuff
purify not bad at all and there's just a
turnaround on that's pretty crazy it's
at two million views i mean no one's
done more for fighter pay than jake paul
how insane is that
three years ago like hey you know like
youtuber jake paul like yeah what about
him oh he's going to be undefeated in
boxing he's been making 40 million
dollars off boxing and then he's also
going to be the on the forefront of
getting fighters paid like you're out of
your goddamn mind
it's amazing
yet
again dana's team and the ufc the best
in marketing by far but when it comes to
[ __ ] with these young kids and this
youtube and this this instagram and
youtube social media culture they just
can't keep up this isn't their game
they're going to lose every single time
i told when dana started talking to him
like this is a bad idea man bad idea
okay another quick one this is cat
zagano
let me get her twitter up here
oh anyways she says she's saying that um
the reason that the fight is not
happening right now with her against
cyborg is because cyborg is refusing a
drug test right here
here in suburbs refusing to drug test
been told my opponent and that's number
one contender match that for march 11th
do i give someone plenty of time to get
their [ __ ] together enough to fight me
by summer
yeah i don't i don't know what's going
on with that and this is captain can you
decline a [ __ ] drug test though i
don't think i don't know how it works in
bellator though
yeah i mean yeah i don't i don't know
the underlyings of bellator so this
cyborg just changed why are you lying i
haven't refused any drug deaths i'm
ready whenever you are behind the scenes
you keep saying bellator you need me
more time to prepare for me you need a
different opponent first now you go on
social media with lies and smear
campaigns and excuses sad
yeah i don't know what's going on there
hopefully they fight but also
all right um this is great news all
charges dismissed against chael sonnen
in the las vegas oh why because some
drunk dude was hitting on his wife
you're dealing with the gangster of
[ __ ] oregon and he beat the [ __ ] out
of you yeah no [ __ ] dude
and how stupid does john look now just
shaming him like i'm gonna hold my
tongue i'm not gonna kick her down yeah
it's because he didn't do anything but
defend his wife from a drunk dumbass i
told you guys not the same
uh doing what's right yeah he's like
that movie kick ass kick ass too
remember when [ __ ] jim carrey he's
like jim carre from kick ass too
he's like dexter basically he's dexter
takes out the bad guys he seems like
just a nice
humble guy yeah nice little guy but then
if [ __ ] hits fan he's the guy you want
to do the exact same thing yeah i know
of course
yeah i told you when i went on the
roundabout trail when that came out so
this is not a similar case at all to
what other guys have done the ufc you're
talking about a guy defending his wife
and again if if you have a wife and
someone was disrespecting her like that
and you wouldn't do that you got a
girlfriend
what is this
this is um just another weird post by
sean strickland i love this guest i
can't get enough of them this is an
apartment tour or well house tour you
have some brows on them [ __ ]
you know different levels of this [ __ ]
right it's like mtv cribs
here's my [ __ ] table motorcycle
helmet i sit here
there might be some more in my coffee
[ __ ] pulleys man i'm a [ __ ] man
opposite i love me
some what
guitar i thought you know what when i
was a kid i was like this is going to
get me laid turns out i can't play the
guitar
a punchy bag something a little bit
overweight so that ryan is
punched [ __ ] that thing
and you [ __ ] said i need
furniture
look at this [ __ ] couch is it
secondhand yes it is but i don't care
all right let's see what else we got
[ __ ] drill press never know you gotta
grill some [ __ ]
show you the kitchen inside
yeah it's [ __ ] pretty glorious
kitchen i gotta i gotta fix this drawer
one day i'll get to it [ __ ] lube
[ __ ] never have too much [ __ ] lube
let's see what else we got here the
gorilla come over there okay guns
you know i got a 76 inch reach you never
know when you gotta reach out and touch
somebody this is like my this is like my
oh [ __ ] i'm going to a sketchy area i
need high capacity i might get a [ __ ]
gun fight
that's that gun
this little [ __ ] is like i'm
going to check the mail i might have to
shoot a crackhead and just like right
there [ __ ] money games out there
all right moving on
oh [ __ ] i forgot
my aftermarket blinds
one day one day i'll get this to close
one day all right let's go to the
[ __ ] bathroom
all this guy kills this bathroom is
pretty [ __ ] special
[Music]
check it out
right i'm still cleaning it but whatever
so the issue the issue that i [ __ ]
have right this [ __ ] this the donald
the valve doesn't work so what you got
to do
what you got to do is you just got to
reach it
you just got to pull up yourself it
works all right
he's living like a bachelor one day i'll
get maintenance after this fight a
little busy we've got the bedroom
that's where all the no magic happens
bed frame
i don't need no [ __ ] bed bedrooms
[ __ ]
[Music]
i'm in vegas you got [ __ ] dry feet
you need lotion by the bed you know what
i mean
yeah
life of [ __ ] luxury
let's [ __ ] go
love them love them even more just an
interesting interesting dude just all he
cares about is fighting and winning yeah
love it
uh
let's see
well this is not that crazy but conor
mcgregor says he's going sober for his
comeback pretty smart yeah of course
i don't know if the the liquor's
helping
uh some of the stuff he's been involved
in but definitely
if he
you can never hate on a guy going sober
so sitting actual of
president can't quite describe it last
week saturday the first day ireland
became free from restriction shout out
to them it's also constantly the
anniversary of the late author guinness
uh all right
all right i'm gonna write path this
honors number for my fine fans i would
say i'm now enjoying myself with my
liquid but very soon i'll be immersing
myself in full training again complete
abstention from the my wonderful
creations of spirit nail just five more
minutes ma
still he's gonna party still but when he
gets ready for training hopefully he's
gonna come up in that five minutes yeah
no cocaine please
kevin holland
uh he was going back and forth to the
internet troll so he invited him over to
the gym and then the troll showed up yep
troll showed up obviously even though
you're a black belt on positive submit
you prove me wrong stop ducking me still
duck me [ __ ] ass and then what happens
and does the kid train at all
so he tries to take him down
oh he's toying what you want to do in
high school ladies and gentlemen
tell them you want to wrestle just can't
you ever get a [ __ ] like that
i think i think more trolls need to get
dealt with yeah and also it's jiu jitsu
it's not like uh
beyonce
yeah
so that's pretty cool
you put one troll down many more to go
yeah
i'm still i'm just kind of like shocked
that these people
would do that and show up
but this what they want right like they
want to you know talk all this [ __ ] then
we see in person the first one you got
an autograph like that's the world we
live in that's social media true and
then he like that troll is gonna go back
and be like yeah see i showed up man
it's like
yeah but then yeah come on but don't
these trolls have girlfriends and [ __ ]
oh yeah hey man i got annihilated by
that guy
you steam people are right [ __ ] like
that on [ __ ] forms and stuff what's
wrong with you i know and i would assume
most of them don't have girlfriends and
that's why they're like this
most likely because they'd have more
stuff to do with their girlfriends other
than doing it with no girls like oh my
god did you send that awful
tweet
you know like no girl
the only reason you hate is to entertain
more guy haters it's a club yeah it's a
real cockfest yeah hating's real [ __ ]
best
okay to each their own
so we've been seeing these uh russian
press conferences for fights and then
they've been getting a little too great
like too crazy right so this one's like
probably the craziest one i've seen so
far um i'll just play this for you this
is better than the guy in the lead
undress doing the jump flying knee and
knocking him out
oh it's almost i'd say this is better oh
wow because it's our two-parter so yes
real quick
that guy's head on the right is
be happy
oh
that was sick
that was this
is russia
he did oh he did hit him with a [ __ ]
flush left hook
which is a cheap shot too
yeah
boy that flying kick was [ __ ] sick
yeah that guy got embarrassed that was
that's awesome that was [ __ ] sick
appear this part for the course
um
we've seen other ones before so
jesus christ
but that was cool those press
conferences are lit yeah
your move ufc
all right that's the only one we can
even compete with was john dc and vegas
yeah because that wasn't even as fun as
that the billboard fell down or they
went the back yeah
that little guy was like
the shoe was thrown it was fun
is that it brother that's it all right
man enjoy the fight night this was it
saturday saturday you got that wild man
tarzan himself in that one bedroom
apartment falling apart shawn strickland
who we're rooting for against jack the
joker herrerson her mansion manson
ransom uh going my boy sean strickland
nothing against the joker jack there but
uh i want uh sean sugar to keep it going
man let's see him get bigger fights i
always assume you have that one bedroom
apartment i'd love to see him get like
real money and see what he does with it
i think he's gonna buy tigers and knives
and guns and i'm all for it uh shout out
to sean strickland enjoy that fight
night uh i will be in atlanta
this thursday friday saturday the tour
strikes back up uh
took all of mainly december january off
and just did shows around la and la
economy is [ __ ] booming we got we're
at the improv
um laugh factory
jumping up at the store so l economy is
coming back man but i just want to be in
town and work on new material stuff like
that but tour is uh it's back this
freaking week man i'm excited to get
back out there see all you guys in
atlanta georgia i've been there about
five years
last time there's bucket theater so now
we're doing the punch line in atlanta
georgia it's more central downtown uh
atlanta so that is the punch line
atlanta georgia this trucking thursday
friday saturday all shows are damn near
sold out we might add shows but right
now if you haven't got tickets go to
fatkz.com or thinkboy.com pick up
tickets for atlanta georgia i think
whatever uh was is next wednesday
february 8th is that right chin let me
take a look
so february 9th it's shaub and friends
back at the hollywood improv those
tickets just went on sale today i'll
have it on the website if you can if
it's not on the website as you're
listing this just go to the
hollywoodimprop.com you'll see it on
there that's february 9th next wednesday
shop and friends we got some monsters
again once you only 8 pm and then
sacramento california with the punch
line sacramento california february 24th
through the 26th and then just announced
just got on uh the website nashville
tennessee uh one of my favorite clubs in
the world zany's shout out to lucy the
manager at zany's nashville tennessee is
march 10th through the 12th uh so i will
be there man chicago end of march get
your tickets at f-a-t-k-z.com or
thinkboy.com uh again can't thank you
guys enough for giving so much love to
thick boy and all the subscribers and
the super cast and doing all the [ __ ] um
yeah man i love you guys thank you for
for giving me this career and also food
truck with francis gano drops this
wednesday as well only on thick boy so
enjoy it man thank you guys for watching
thanks for listening like definitely
subscribe to think boy channel we have
so much stuff going on there the new
cats after dark king of the sting with
chappelle
chan cat and nick is gonna drop uh as
well on think boy only so you get all
that man all right love you guys atlanta
i will see you this thursday friday
saturday tickets to fatkz.com stay thick
for all you that run the tough mudder
love you guys thanks for doing that with
me we had so much fun i will keep you
posted on the next one but let's rally
the troops man told you guys could do it
these things just keep growing and
growing into a monster so those thick
mudders are too much fun man i'll
announce the next one very soon love you
guys stay thick stay safe most
importantly see you next time
you